I told you everything!
I don't know where she is and even if I did I'd never tell you. I
would never
tell you. I know it's difficult to accept that she's a very dangerous individual. If she contacts you, you must tell us.
Otherwise your putting yourself and entire family at risk.
Do you understand Michael?
Michael?
On Halloween night, Will saw a sort of shadow.
Maybe all this is happening for a reason.
Nightmares is happening and it all leads back to here.
This thing, you said it was all in his head.
And what have you done? Nothing!
What is wrong with my boy?!?
I don't understand.
Eleven would, she always did
It's like reaching into Hawkins.
If anyone knows how to destroy this thing, it's Will.
Oh my god.
Don't you think it's weird how we always seem to hang out when the world's about to end?
It's not like it was before it's grown. It's Judgment Day.
Which is why we need as much help as we can get.
Is there anyone there? Anyone?!?
You should go now, it's almost here.
You still have that bat?
Bat? What bat?
The one with the nails.
You